coming up next week at the Strasburg
plenary MEP slicker hands the upcoming
European Council future action on
climate change and a little matter of a
fond farewell welcome to the agenda as
European leaders try to relaunch the
European project at next month's
european council could any peace perhaps
help to inject new momentum ahead of the
summit the focus relations with Russia
trade and migration at the last memory
session any peace rejected a commission
proposal that could allow member states
to deduct the numbers of Syrian refugees
they take from Turkey from those seeking
asylum here they pledged to relocate
from Greece and Italy m ep's have also
called for greater unity in countering
Russian aggression the ternary debate
takes place on Wednesday when a former
european commissioner who had previously
laid down the law for Europe doesn't
follow best practice it's a little more
than a boo-boo the former European
Commissioner for competition Nelly crows
has found herself in hot water after
been implicated in the bahama papers it
would appear that she never relinquished
her position in an offshore company
during her tenure the malaise has also
caught the attention of the European
Ombudsman who is questioning the
appointment of the former EU Commission
chief Barroso to Goldman Sachs a lively
debate is no doubt set for Tuesday very
peaceful quiz representatives of the
Commission on the business shenanigans
of their former top brass with the
ceasefire in tatters it can there be a
diplomatic resolution to conflict in
Syria all attempts to revive the
short-lived cease fire dat fell apart on
September 19th following attack on a un
aid convoy are stalling as both Russia
and the US are unable to come to terms
Emmy peas will discuss the way ahead for
Syria along with having a separate
debate on Columbia a referendum is set
to be held there on it to the second to
sign off on a historic peace deal with
FARC rebels both debates in marked for
Wednesday and now with an amusing brief
growth stagnation despite progress to
decrease dent any Peas debate greases
outlook on Tuesday a final agreement on
mules prevent the trade in goods and
services that may
contribute to torture or execution is
expected to get parliamentary approval
on Tuesday mep will vote on rhe
industrialization policy and take a look
at caterpillar and allston restructuring
plans at machinery maker caterpillar and
train manufacturer Austin could put
thousands of jobs at stake at factories
across Belgium France and Northern
Ireland Morocco will be the venue for
their next climate change conference at
cop 22 but a little matter of the
ratification of the cop21 Paris
agreement still lingers the council is
expected to ratify the cop21 agreement
the first big global undertaking to
reduce co2 emissions to be ready by
seven October if that happens it paved
the way for the road ahead plans for
copper 22 include Morocco's Energy
Initiative to switch to fifty percent
renewable energy by 2013 the climate
change debate takes place at plenary on
Wednesday okay well that's a wrap for me
this is my last agenda my last program
for Europe all TV take care and provide